hey guys my name is Peter Shankman and
I'm here tonight in an IMAX theatre
where we're about to go and take a whole
bunch of people who think they've just
seen a regular version of Godzilla we're
gonna IMAX upgrade them so they
experience Godzilla in 3d like nothing
they've ever seen before
it's gonna be an awesome night ready
so we would like to take everyone in
this room upstairs for free and show you
how
you see Godzilla on a 100-foot screen in
3d
the biggest boldest most awesome roller
coaster of an experience I've ever it
was fun this was my first IMAX movie
that I've been to absolute fantastic
didn't know the screen was that big
didn't know the sound quality was so
amazing is that full that full coming
after that made that would be way better
would recommend that anybody felt like
Godzilla was about that himself we felt
like we were in the middle of San
Francisco while I was getting ripped
down swag back and two free IMAX passage
to any future IMAX more this was being
treated at absolutely like a VIP
experience so I thought was one with the
movie the IMAX visuals the iMac sound
the depth of field you feel like you're
in the middle of
that's down on my mat my maxilla would
see a movement
you